after doing a very in-depth spoiler
review based off of
your questions and then doing a fun
video that i really encourage you guys
to go check out where we ask
the most puzzling questions after
watching ww84
it's time to bring it home with ryan
george's pitch
meeting for wonder woman 1984 because
after we did those questions
literally as i was like tagging
uploading the videos like man i got way
more questions
and then sure enough you guys in the
comments put way more questions down and
now let's see what ryan george points
out
that we haven't even thought of
ourselves let's see there's something
i'm sure i'll be like yeah i thought of
that
forgot to mention in our video but i'm
sure there's going to be some where
we're like oh that's such a good point
you think about that
good points are tight and also for those
asking cobra kai reaction should start
going up
tomorrow so keep a lookout for that
so you have a wonder woman sequel for me
yes sir i do so we're going to start the
movie with diana as a kid back in
themyscira okay okay and what's she up
to well she's competing in the amazon
version of that tv show wipeout and she
tries to use a shortcut to win and
learns
that cheating is wrong sure okay that's
a nice quick message to start the movie
off it's going to take a full 11 minutes
so then we're going to jump forward when
this movie takes place
okay okay so like 30 40 years ago oh i
don't enjoy that that's a true thing so
anyway diane is still super
heartbroken about steve trevor dying in
the first movie he's all she can think
about really after all that time yeah
well i mean you got to understand this
was a really good guy she knew for a
couple of days
anyway working in washington dc at the
smithsonian and she has a new co-worker
named barbara
what's her deal well she's a freaking
nerd sir she can't even walk in
heels oh embarrassing disgusting and
pathetic nobody likes her
[Laughter]
very magical stone this phony business
guy max lord he gets his hand on it and
he wishes to become the dream stone oh
so he turns to stone
you would think so the way that was
phrased but no now he can grant people's
wishes when they touch him such a good
point
diana get wishes before he does that
they do barbara wishes to be more like
diana so she gets some nice clothes and
some super strength and now she can walk
in heels well that's impressive am i
right
she's not pathetic anymore also she
removes her glasses which as you know
makes people automatically more
attractive that's just good character
development is what that is and so diane
is getting the trevor to come back to
life and this way we can get chris pine
back in the movie i know people like
chris pine so what does he just appear
out of thin air actually no his
consciousness goes into this random
guy's body so everybody sees this random
guy but we see chris pine so okay is
this because the stone can't make things
just magically show up no it absolutely
can a giant wall is gonna appear out of
nowhere so are some new i mean the thing
is magic
are we doing this weird body control
thing with steve i don't know what
happens to this guy's consciousness
while steve's controlling his body
who's to say you are yeah what if this
guy has a job in the family he has for
other people
where is his consciousness is he dead oh
well here's the reason
i need you to get all the way off my
back about this body control thing get
off of there oh that felt vaguely
threatening so i'm gonna get off your
back about that right and so then steve
and diana obviously they get intimate
because you know they love each other
they do that using a stranger's body
that's got to be crossing a line that's
not okay well we're gonna have them do
it anyway
and i find it strange that you
immediately got back on my back about
that i mean it's actually a really easy
fix just have steve trevor show up as
himself no ah so then that max lord guy
makes himself super rich and he goes to
egypt to take some guy's oil and make
himself even richer okay so steve and
diana they gotta get over there you know
how are they gonna do that well the
thing is they can't just take a
commercial flight because steve doesn't
have a passport no i mean the guy he's
possessing probably has one yeah well
they don't check for that they have
a smithsonian steal one of the
okay he was a pilot in world war one
these are those those are different
areas well i mean a plane is a plane
that's i mean okay yeah that sentence is
not
technically wrong so there you go but
okay sir a plane is a plane are you
implying that a plane's not a plane
because a plane is a plane
i mean that's just the plane is applying
a statement a plane is a plane
okay so then they're being chased
because of the jet theft and so wonder
woman goes ahead and makes it invisible
and that's how she gets her invisible
jet
what how well turns out that's a thing
she can do so she does the thing that
she can do
well thank god she has that ability we
never once mentioned a reference
scene with max lord oh very exciting but
he freaking gets away and he goes around
causing a bunch more chaos then he goes
to see the president of the united
states
what for well he gets the president to
wish for more nukes and then he sees
this technology just lying around in the
oval office and it's exactly what he
needs what do you mean what's this
device that lets him take over
everybody's screen around the world so
technically through like satellite waves
he is you know he's touching them how oh
don't worry about it oh okay i won't so
then there's going to be this fight in
the white house and barbara
she's turning evil so she gets in on
that too okay and steve manages to grab
max lord oh and so he wishes for
everything to go back to normal oh yeah
no that would have been smart instead he
pushes him around a bit yeah
also a decent strategy so then max lord
escapes
very sad but then she starts to fly and
lasso some lightning bolts so that's
pretty cool that's
that's not bad oh sure yeah that may as
well happen so then diane is going to
have this
by the way is a cat now what yeah she's
a cat now she's part cheetah what are
you talking about
hey anything else you want and she's
like yes actually i would like to be an
apex predator please so she could have
just as easily been turned into a killer
whale yeah i guess there was a chance
she could have turned into a you know
orca whale but that would have made for
a less interesting fight scene oh i
wholeheartedly
fight scene and disagree gonna get
electrocuted no so she dies
no she gets a little sleepy which is
what happens when cats get electrocuted
that's not
no i don't think that's accurate well
that's what my dad told me when my
childhood cat chewed through his
extension cord
your cat died i think no sir he went to
sleep then he went to live on a farm and
i never saw him again brian george has a
cat
okay so what happens next oh well max is
granting wishes to everybody in the
world through their screens
most of the world doesn't speak english
okay yeah i'll keep that in mind for
trivia night i guess that's interesting
anyway it's to be complete chaos oh it
is
people are killing each other with
wishes one guy gets a farm outside his
apartment people can wish for anything
really yeah it's going to be nuts
statistically speaking wouldn't at least
one person wish for the guy that just
showed up on their tv to die
or for the world to end wouldn't at
least one person wish for world peace
what happens with that paradox
that's like a one in a million kind of
whip right there are billions of people
which is full of fun trivia tonight so
anyway diana has to lasso this guy but
her lasso can't get through this
mysterious wind around him oh wow it's
gonna be tough for her to defeat him if
she can't reach him
actually it's gonna be super easy barely
an inconvenience oh really
yeah see she gets her lasso around his
ankle and then she can talk to everybody
through him i thought she couldn't get
through with that thing oh yeah no she
couldn't but then
she could but how completely relocated
so then she tells everybody to renounce
their wishes because nothing good comes
from lying and everybody does it
everybody does it including max lord who
suddenly cares about his son that he's
been actively ignoring the whole movie
and so what about like what if someone
with a terminal illness wished to be
cured
well they would have they would have to
renounce that because that's
that's not the truth
to be able to see that's uh that's a
shortcut
uh to being able to see so that's that's
wrong
if somebody wished to be able to feed
their starving child yeah okay this
moment only works if everybody wishes
for something selfish or violent so
we're gonna have to pretend like that's
the case okay
oh pretending is tight okay let's do it
okay thank god so then max lloyd is
going to go reunite with his son who
just kind of comes running out
you know get back from the island if he
renounced all his wishes
and what happens with barbara oh she's
not a cat anymore and she's
she's chilling i imagine okay anyway
then diana's gonna have a little flirty
moment with the guy who steve was
controlling it's gonna be very sweet
he's already seen that guy naked yeah
just a real sweet moment it's gonna be
crazy
makes it better and then she looks at a
balloon and we're all done so what do
you think
i mean i feel like using a strange man's
body is just so deeply strange and
raises so many messed up questions
right right right well maybe nobody will
think of how weird it is well yeah i
guess that is a possibility okay let's
do it
[Music]
hell yeah hey guys ryan here thank you
oh i hope you liked it if you did you
know i did that was great
subscribe button wrote down six things i
did not
also let me know if you have ideas for
other movies i should do pitches for as
always check back soon for a new video
bye-bye
bye ryan john ryan that was great all
right so i wrote down a few things that
definitely were not really touched on
whether or swell the review or wtf
i mean that was hilarious as as expected
every pitch meeting is great i haven't
seen a bad pitch meeting he's
solid he was talking about the opening
of how that goes on for 11 minutes that
goes on way too long and i've heard the
arguments back and forth
is that opening even all that necessary
for this
movie like we already kind of have two
openings in this film
as it is i wanted to point out something
that actually really irked me the first
time i saw it that i don't hear anyone
talk about
i hated the cliche moment when a little
diana is riding her horse and going
through all these crazy obstacles and
everything
and then she gets hit by a bush
one little branch of a tree which
happens to be the shortcut
right there give her the eye that moment
is the part that really annoyed me out
of all that
you mean to tell me this little warrior
woman who's just done all the craziest
most impossible things
gets hit by the the cliche bush really
really hyper awareness demonstration of
her surroundings
the rules of the stone are so back and
forth and
all over the place in jumbled when he
points out uh so maxwell lord he said he
turns into the stone
yeah yeah that's true by the way he
phrased that question
wouldn't he could just turn into the
stone i think that would have been a
much funnier
story howdy's just immortalized there
forever
nobody gets to make any more wishes in
the movies so solid
and like yeah we've talked plenty about
the whole thing with
why couldn't steve have just appeared
instead of just appeared in some guy's
body and out of all the questions that
were raised from that and we've raised
quite a bit too
what happens to the guy's consciousness
i never even thought about
that simplistic part of it yeah where
does it go is it forced to the back like
a demon possession
yeah nowhere for right now is it some
purgatory
state is it existed in some type of like
soul ethereal plane
type of arena you know yeah he's stuck
in the movie soul
yeah he's one of the women guys he's
been pushed out of the wrong
body that counts off well and this made
me wonder too and i hadn't even thought
at the time
what about all the other people who
probably wished for loved ones back
are there a whole bunch of other people
getting body swapped as well yeah
like it really does seem like there are
a lot of things that i feel like you can
actually let go of if you want to not
nitpick but this is one where i'm like
why did they
make a specific device out of this when
you know that like half the world's
gonna wish for a loved one back exactly
exactly i mean he points out the thing
too about uh the passport situation
about how that guy
could probably had a passport yeah they
didn't even think about that either
no one the smithsonian just keeps fully
stocked jets on hand i guess i don't
know that i love that hole the plane is
a plane plane
yeah it's all the same even though this
got
jets on it now maybe there's a way to
argue this point that he makes about
house when steve has maxwell lord uh
pinned up how steve in that moment
because diana made the wish brings steve
back but steve hasn't made his wish yet
so steve could make that wish
put things back to normal or leave the
stone or something like that like he can
make some kind of wish himself but
doesn't that whole time
that thought never occurred to me and
maybe they didn't know if that's the way
to do it or the way to go about it or
like oh there was probably some bigger
end game they needed to solve first i i
don't know something it stands to reason
that he could have made that wish in
that very moment
yeah and i hadn't even thought of that
but that's a perfect point seems like
it's well within
steve's motivations and whatnot i'm a
little surprised that nobody caught that
yeah dude process you know the other
part this is
so true most of the world doesn't speak
english
and he's broadcasting this out to the
whole world and most of them don't speak
english
such a great point like did they have a
live translator on hand
for this like interruption no one
planned
for i mean the paradox of the wishes of
the contradictory wishes has been one of
the
biggest debated parts of this of like
wait a minute there's billions of people
and they're all making wishes some
people are bound to make wishes that
just contradict each other
so how do you make them all come true
but the part about the english
english moment that's true yeah most
don't speak english
[Music]
oh brian george is the best you know
ryan george really is the best it's
weird how it's like it's come from like
cinemasins to honest trailers and then
you just got this one guy
one guy talking back and forth he's both
broken in the holes
in the front who's become my favorite
this is so so solid
well guys if you haven't done so already
subscribe to pitch meeting check out our
videos that we've done on wonder woman
1984 as well
hit that like button we'll catch you
guys soon